our first speaker kicking off our
program this morning is Julius crime
previously an investment analyst at
various private equity and hedge fund
firms he is the founder and editor of
American affairs a journal of political
thought and policy launched in 2017
American Affairs is an extension or grew
out of the Journal of American greatness
a now-defunct blog site that sought to
offer an intellectual defense or
explanation of the Trump campaign in
which achieved a certain measure of Fame
in 28 2016 President Trump of course
rejected the traditional Republican
embrace of free trade during the
campaign in favour of an American trade
policy that puts American interests
first
needless to say Trump's political
success has forced a serious rethinking
of the issue of trade on the part of
conservatives one of the places that
this much-needed rethinking is happening
is in the pages of the journal edited by
our next speaker the journal covers a
variety of topics including economics
and trade which is the subject of our
talk this morning would you please
welcome to the podium Julius crime
[Applause]
thank you very much for that
introduction thank you for inviting me
here I also want to begin by thanking
you or thanking hillsdale for coming up
with the title how to think about trade
I did not come up with that title I'm
not quite sure who did but I'm very I'm
very grateful for it
for one bad reason one good reason the
bad reason is that it reminds me of a
lot of colleges today that say they're
not you know there to teach anyone facts
or impart any knowledge they're just
there to teach people how to think and
so if everything I say turns out to be
completely wrong just remember I'm not
telling you what to think about trade
only how to think about trade but more
seriously I actually think it is the
right question or the more decisive
question when it comes to trade because
trade afterall is a pretty neutral
phenomenon it can be good it can be bad
it depends on the context the purposes
and many other things what's interesting
today is how sort of ideologized our
trade policy has become and you see that
primarily I think in a lot of the
political rhetoric on trade which treats
it as something that is very simple it's
been settled since David Ricardo in the
19th century it's two plus two equals
four there's no questions it's that easy
Greg Mankiw Harvard economist for
example recently wrote an op-ed in The
New York Times in which he's talking
about lawnmowers and people not mowing
their own lawns and this is supposed to
be you know relevant or a sensible
metaphor for the global economy and
what's happening in our current trade
policy now if you actually look or go
into serious academic economic
discussions on trade no one actually
takes this seriously even very pro trade
economists will admit as say Larry
Summers has or Brad DeLong has
that the the sort of economics 101
lessons on trade are not really accurate
and much more complicated discussion is
required nevertheless a lot of these
people DeLong specifically and
explicitly says well ok the Ricardian
metaphors aren't really accurate but
they're useful in convincing people who
can't grasp the higher technical
knowledge but this is a very strange
approach to something is you know really
what should be as neutral as trade why
do we feel that we have to convince
people of this free trade ideology
especially by dishonest means and I
think you know the reality is that what
we call free trade doesn't really exist
it's really become trade of course
exists but free trade is really an
ideology and it's very attractive for a
number of reasons I think first because
it's a lot of the allure is that under
the free trade model basically everyone
is a winner you don't have to do
anything you're always a winner and even
when it seems like you're most a loser
such as when you're your industry is
getting transferred to China you can
still call yourself a winner because oh
they're just subsidizing our consumption
the other ideology behind it of course
is one that has been very popular among
a lot of conservatives in which the
market is basically said above
everything else including any sense of
political community the country the
nation whatever and so all these this
narrative is very attractive for those
reasons and another interesting thing
with the way a lot of people think about
trade or how they think about trade is
that even a lot of critics have tend to
focus on purely distributional elements
of it and this critique often ends up
serving the sort of overall Pro trade
narrative because it basically says
everything is working fine everything is
great it's just some people have been
left behind some of the gains haven't
been distributed as equitably as they
might have
if we fix this everything will be
perfect what I'm going to argue today is
actually that the problem is much deeper
than that it's not it's not you know
these problems are inherent in the
system itself it's not just a sort of
failure of an isolated instance to deal
with certain distributional elements but
the trade system that we have embraced
the main function of it is actually to
make long-term decline profitable in the
short term and that's why it's so
deceptively appealing and the main
reason it's been so destructive so I
will start where basically everyone
starts with this which is a discussion
of manufacturing what you see there
there are two charts the one on the left
I think yeah is from the Heritage
Foundation is a very typical Heritage
Foundation chart they're saying see look
free-trade is wonderful they're talking
about NAFTA in particular here see
manufacturing output has gone up since
NAFTA no problem now I'm not going to
focus specifically on NAFTA I'm much
more interested in Chinese accession to
the WTO which happened around 2000 and
that picture I think is very interesting
and heritage never really talks about
this but if you look at that chart it's
true that output hasn't you know fallen
off a cliff but it's basically stagnant
since 2000 and this is the period of
slowest growth that there's never been a
comparable I guess now 18 year period of
stagnation in US manufacturing output
the other thing people talk about is the
next chart there we should say Oh see
you know employment has gone down but
output has stayed flat or even gone up
so it's really just we're getting more
competitive it's no problem it's good
actually the problem with this is that
one if you're going through a major
productivity boom the natural outcome is
not that your production stays flat you
may lose some employment but
presumably if your industry is more
productive than anywhere there's going
to be a ton of investment flooding in
wanting to take advantage of this high
productivity your output should be
rising and an even more obvious problem
us productivity is not going up it's
going down quite significantly since
2000 so where is all this productivity
going you know is productivity the real
explanation for what's happening and
here when you get to the actual market
share you see the real decline the US
has gone from about 18 percent of
manufacturing export market share to 9
percent half well hopefully you can also
see from the chart if it's large enough
their China has gone from 6 to 18 this
is where the decline is most obvious and
and where you can really see it now some
would still argue well so what we're
shedding some very low value
manufacturing jobs apparel things of
this nature
but again the data don't really bear
that out
this is high-tech manufacturing US has
gone from 40 percent to 30 percent when
it comes to high-tech exports the
decline again is something like you know
12% 7% and if that chart there is from
2008 on if you go back further the u.s.
is actually a net exporter of high-tech
high value-added products around 2000
and now we're a major importer with
China the major exporter and if you
actually look at what we import from
China you know of course we have lost
you know any commodity apparel
manufacturing and things like that but a
lot of the imports are high value-added
project products electrical machinery
machinery things like that and with the
technology transfers that are part and
parcel of all of our trade agreements
this problem basically gets worse all
the time
what about employment I don't want to
dwell too much on this but I do think
it's worth going through it because it
does have impacts even beyond the
distributional levels so I apologize
this chart is somewhat outdated I
couldn't get the BLS website to work
when I was putting this together but
it's basically correct and if you draw
the chart out to a little more recently
you'll see a bigger increase in business
and professional services employment and
a rebound in construction but other than
that it's basically the same the jobs
we've lost are in manufacturing everyone
knows that but maybe more interestingly
information the supposed jobs of the
future
we're losing those to where we're
gaining them education and health
services and that's mostly health
services we'll talk about that more
leisure and hospitality
not exactly a hotbed of high value-added
strategic dominance and professional and
business services which we can see here
on the next slide hopefully you can see
this slide the chart on the right is
healthcare jobs where most of these
healthcare jobs coming personal care
aides home health aides nursing
assistants basically the lowest end of
the spectrum likewise on the other chart
they're the largest component of
business and professional services is
actually administrative and waste
services that's one of those green dots
in the lower right corner
not exactly the job of the future I
think that was envisioned as well as
retail trade and food and drinking
service so the reason I point this out
is not only the distributional effects
were which are you know I'll discuss
frequently and well-known but I think
the real point here the real concern
here and by the way I do think the
distributional effects are real and are
a problem but the even deeper problem of
which this is a symptom of is basically
we are d skilling our population we are
moving down not up the value chain
it's exactly the opposite of what the
free trade agenda was supposed to do and
what was promised to put an even finer
point on that here's employment in
Telecom on a downhill trajectory and in
terms of computing and manufacturing
down significantly and software
publishing up a little bit but we're
talking about a very small number here
so the new economy jobs hopefully it's
clear simply haven't materialized as
promised right now as a matter of fact
there are more people in this country
who make their living driving than in
all of manufacturing certainly in all of
software design and things like that the
job of the Information Age economy has
turned out to be an uber driver welcome
to the Future and again at this point I
think everyone's aware of this but I
don't I don't think we talked enough
about what's deeper behind it and the
reason why simply redistributing more
can't be a solution is what I'm going to
try to address next and the point is the
problem is not that we're so productive
that we just have so many people that we
don't know what to do with them as I
showed earlier but actually that our
productivity is declining our our
economic dynamism is declining the core
pillars of support for our economy are
being eroded and they're being eroded to
maximize basically short-term
shareholder profits and that's the main
reason are we are pursuing the trade
policy we are pursuing it's the main
it's the main effect essentially and so
as you can see here when you don't have
when you don't have productivity gains
effectively the way you increase
corporate profits is you you cut
as we just discussed you cut wages you
might call these charts kind of like a
Karl Marx's revenge but that's that's
basically what's happening this is you
know corporate profit margins and in and
of itself this this wouldn't inherently
be a bad thing but what's interesting is
that we're not taking these increased
profits among other things gained from
shifting productive activity into low
cost jurisdictions like China and we're
not investing them and said what we're
doing is we are taking them and
recycling them into financial assets
without any productive investment and
this is why goods services are going to
have to acknowledge the fact that
frankly trickle-down economics in my
lifetime has been a complete disaster
and you get a lot of bubble economies
but you don't actually get any per
capita GDP growth you don't get
productivity growth and in the long term
your economy continues to stagnate and
become more and more imbalanced this is
corporate non-residential investment
pretty obvious there it's on a downward
trajectory again around 2000 starts to
be a very significant date again
interestingly perhaps even perhaps even
more interesting this is investment in
ICT sector again this is supposed to be
the future that's in steep decline as
well the corporate R&D spending picture
is not quite as dire but it is still
stagnant flat since 2000 and government
R&D this has nothing to do with trade
necessarily but it's also in decline and
I just show that because in some what
we're effectively doing is we're not
investing in new technologies anymore
we're not investing in more productive
uses we're transferring our old
technologies to China
other low-wage jurisdictions to get a
short-term boost in profits from cheap
labor and thus you find yourself in a
low productivity country a country that
is increasingly losing its dominance in
the high value-added sectors for example
if you look at the remaining
semiconductor chip manufacturing in the
US the last ones in the US are the ones
basically owned by the defense industry
by Lockheed and things like that if you
talk to people in these industries you
know they'll tell you these are two to
three generations behind anything in
Asia
and I don't know why anyone be surprised
by that at this point but China's
rapidly catching up to us in in many
areas in many cases they are probably
ahead and so what actually can we do
about this I think in general I'm pretty
supportive of the Trump agenda so far as
was alluded to in the introduction if I
have a concern however it's that it's
not really being done as part of a
larger systemic project there doesn't
seem to be a longer-term plan
particularly as it applies to key
high-priority technological areas which
are going to be much more difficult to
address don't get me wrong I have no
problem with having a domestic steel
industry as I'll discuss later a lot of
these commodity manufacturing can be
very important I have no problem with
having LNG exports and a healthy energy
sector in many cases the energy sector
and hydraulic fracturing all that is
probably a lot more high-tech than the
photo-sharing apps that we celebrate as
the tech industry but the issue is that
if we only focus on on these industries
we may accelerate rather than reverse
our decline into a brazilian-style
economy and I think history suggests
that while natural resources raw
materials are important it's not exactly
the way to achieve economic
strategic dominance so in addition to
what has been done on on you know those
sort of individual tariff fronts with
the tax reform recently I think it had a
lot of good things in it it reduces some
of the benefits of offshoring it also
some of the measures applied to foreign
income I think we're useful but I think
much more could be done in particular
again the problem as I've tried to show
is not just trade it's a lot of the idle
capital that sits and goes only into
financial assets so I personally would
like to see something like a you know
harsher penalty on share buybacks things
like that
fairly unproductive uses of capital and
do more to reward more productive
investment another issue
larger scale issue that I think will
have to be addressed if trade in general
is going to be addressed is what I can
only call are sort of pseudo floating or
quasi floating post Bretton Woods
currency regime which so far there
really hasn't been any significant
discussion about but the way the system
works basically is if you had any real
economic expansion in the US or if you
started applying tariffs you know much
more broadly the inevitable consequence
of be that the US dollar would rise and
you'd effectively undermine the outcome
you're trying to produce and that's why
the countries that have succeeded most
under this regime are ones that have
basically rejected the floating model
China most conspicuously also Germany
which can use the euro to effectively
suppress the value of what a what a real
German currency otherwise would be but
the US with a floating currency it's
very difficult to actually pursue an
effective trade policy to really pursue
an agenda of internal development one
interesting development on this this is
a Bloomberg article it's about the bond
someone at the bond management firm
PIMCO came out recently and said you
know the US has long
started a new sort of Cold War in in
global currencies and basically other
central banks are allowing the US dollar
to weaken out of fear that protectionist
measures if they don't now I have no
idea if it's true I hope it is it makes
sense but what's interesting about this
is that you know in the past we actually
did address this problem very directly
this is what the plaza Accord was about
in 1985 the US needed a way to raise
interest rates without having a
catastrophic increase in the value of
the dollar we basically went to Japan
the main problem at the time and others
we addressed this we negotiated it it
was straightforward it was a strategy
and it worked but that's completely
absent from any discussion now and as
long as it is I think it'll be very
difficult for us to to deal with our
problems a lot of economists have
thought that currency trading and
currency levels are simply a matter of
interest rates and inflation but as
PIMCO as fortunately realizing here it's
there's always a political competition
in these things and it's not really a
market and the final thing I think we
actually need to be serious about is a
radical rethinking of how we consider
the the role of the state and the
economy and the strategic value of the
economy and the ultimate purpose of
having a healthy economy you know the
fact is that China has been pursuing a
very intelligent effective government
led industrial policy for 30 years and
it's working better than ours we don't
have one and as long as that continues I
don't I don't see any other outcome
other than continued decline now there's
a lot of risks involved with sort of
industrial policy but again as long as
China can do it we can't we'll keep
losing for example or one example of how
this might take shape I don't know if
you saw it recently there was a news
item a lot of us sort of Homeland
Security Intelligence Agency said don't
use Huawei phones Huawei phones are bad
there you know Huawei is a Chinese
company it has a lot of links with the
Chinese military etc and this is
probably true although a cynical side of
me looks at this and says you know this
I wonder how much Apple lobbied for this
and it all rings a little bit hollow
when all the US cell phones are made in
China anyway and all the US broadband
infrastructure is increasingly made in
China so if we're going to do that then
let's be serious about it and let's go
to Apple and say okay we'll let you have
your monopoly and we'll defend you from
Huawei but you're going to take some of
your cash hoard and you're going to
invest it in these key priorities you're
going to hire some people in the US
you're gonna build some things in the US
and Carl Icahn is not gonna like it but
too bad and we can do the same thing
with Google and Facebook and all of them
if you want to keep your monopoly if you
want to avoid extensive antitrust and
tax evasion issues maybe you should
start thinking about what you owe the
United States the other things of course
could be done is if the private sector
won't invest the state will have to do
it presumably led by the Defense
Department as it was in the past but
certainly an increase in government
funding for research seems quite
critical at the moment in addition to
any conventional revisions of trade
agreements that that minimize the the
benefits of offshoring and technology
transfers and all of that now I would be
the first to admit that what I just
outlined it's very aspirational and
there's no real concrete motion of
anything in that direction so I think
it's worth actually just exploring it
but further what the future looks like
if the current course remains in place
one possible outcome is
the system actually corrects itself
there's been a lot of talk about wage
increases recently it's it's possible
although if I can steal a chart from
David Goldman's 82 times column you know
not sure how much the data actually
bears that out yet
I would also speculate that we're in the
process of or there will soon be
something of a cyclical uptake in
capital expenditures and investment but
if I had to guess I would say that the
corporate sector will do the absolute
minimum possible and that it won't
really be enough to change course the
other outcome possible is that we
actually do move toward the sort of
truly globalized nirvana nation-states
disappear national economies disappear
we just have a sort of indistinct mass
of shareholders and indistinct units of
GDP all trading together but I'm
skeptical about this for a couple of
reasons one is the political legitimacy
issues which again I think are quite
widely discussed today you see that in
Europe a lot to put that into a specific
trade context you see it a lot of these
trade agreements now pretty much all of
them include what are called isds or
investor state dispute settlement
provisions and basically isds developed
it was a way to deal with new post
colonial regimes you know several
decades ago that didn't have court
systems and investors needed a way to
have some kind of adjudication for
claims in countries that you know we're
new countries and had no reliable court
systems interestingly however over the
last couple decades isds has fallen out
of favor in the developing world but
it's actually become very much
entrenched in trade agreements between
developed countries the countries that
actually have the court systems that
that should make it unnecessary but what
is D s basically says is that national
courts are not adequate to judge
disputes between investors and
and therefore we need a separate court
system basically run by a lot of
arbitration lawyers fairly opaque etc to
do this and even though nothing like
this or you know the extreme outcomes
haven't happened in the US yet the logic
of the system is pretty clear if
standard court systems and government
systems can't be used to judge disputes
between investors and governments why
should they be able to judge disputes
between anyone in the government why
should they be allowed to adjudicate any
claims between any parties and that's
the direction you're going and
eventually you know you'll end up with a
sort of legal and governmental system
that's completely divorced from any
actually existing nation state or other
political body even though it relies on
those governments and political bodies
to enforce and uphold it so that's one
problem beyond that and probably more
importantly I think the economics of the
system the free trade system is we call
it our self undermining as I've tried to
show they the result is a descaling of
advanced countries the result is moving
down the value chain it's inimical to
development it's not positive for
development there's a lot of rhetoric
about how we need to do free trade
because it's good for the world
it's actually and this is from
experience as a emerging market frontier
market investor and so on it's actually
pretty bad for the world so to speak
it's good for countries that abuse it
like China it's good for large capital
holders in the West but for everyone
else it's actually quite problematic and
the the reason is that not only does it
reward the abusers of the system like
China it actually relies upon them for
the system to keep working you need to
have constantly new low-wage geographies
new low-cost geographies opening up but
to have that you need a certain minimum
level of investment infrastructure basic
services in order to allow for that new
and
much like China had and the free trade
agenda that we actually promote through
the IMF and others in these countries
actually makes that impossible for say
Africa to become the next China there
are other factors too of course
corruption cultural issues all of that
but the trade is an issue and as long as
you have a trade system that basically
tells people if it's more expensive to
develop than import just import no one
develops and if no one develops the
system eventually runs out of gas it's
worth sort of just putting this into a
little bit deeper theoretical context
what you see there are sort of charts of
the industrial diversity of two
countries Ghana and Germany now Ghana
would appear to be the paragon of
Ricardian comparative advantage they
focus on what they're good at nothing
more and Germany looks like a totally
inefficient basket case they have an
economy that's all over the place they
haven't specialized at all but we all
know that you know I've been to Ghana a
number of times I wouldn't apply some of
the language that our president has to
it but if you're comparing Ghana and
Germany I don't think there's any
question of where you want to live and
the reason is because as you know people
in real industry know people like Andy
Grove of Intel and others the way you
develop an economy is you don't send
everybody into fast food service and
emptying bedpans and then expect them to
come up with a new silicon wafer you
actually have to build your industries
and build adjacent industries and from
that you get innovation and increase in
complexity and moving up the value chain
but the free trade paradigm that we
promote is completely hostile to that
and as a result what you're going to
have is one of two things for the system
to keep working you're either going to
need countries to opt out of it and
start pursuing their own development
paths or to more likely at this point
you will have China lead the investment
in them for its own mercantilist ik
purposes
which it has no problem doing but then
when they actually do develop to become
fit for investment they are not going to
be aligned with some us-led free trade
model they're going to be aligned with
and dependent on China and this is
really the final reason why I would say
that the current system won't work and
that's the China shows no inclination to
give up its own national interest
whatever president Zi says too gullible
crowds at Davos what he says at home is
very different and they have as I said
been very effective Trump Trump got a
lot of criticism for it but I think he's
right they've been far more effective
than any US leadership for the past
thirty years at promoting their own
interests now when when these arguments
are prevented are presented to a lot of
American audiences particularly those
with a strong ideological or practical
interests in defending free trade
there's usually two two main objections
the first one is well what about Google
and Facebook and all these tech giants
these are great companies you know no
one will ever catch them and all of that
and I'm very concerned about about this
you know using this as our our main
national champions and the pillars of
our economy because what distinguishes
you know our so-called tech companies
now it's not really any advantage in
technology web 2.0 is pretty old at this
point it's really a network effect it's
it's the sort of you know the economies
of scale and if everyone's a member of
Facebook it makes Facebook infinitely
more valuable than any other social
network somebody else might create and
their sort of natural monopolies and you
can't compete with them but when this is
your core advantage that makes you very
vulnerable to political change political
competition for example Facebook and
Google are basically minor players
wherever the
u.s. political order is not dominant
Facebook and Google are not significant
in Russia they use VK and Yandex
in China they have WeChat and y bo and
Alibaba
rather than Amazon even even the
Europeans when they get angry at the
United States what they do is they
launch a privacy investigation into
Google or something or a data use
investigation the point is that these
things are very vulnerable to the
overall political dynamic and as you
have more and more countries move into a
Chinese sphere of influence the Facebook
and Google sphere of influence is going
to shrink accordingly and all of a
sudden people are going to be using
WeChat rather than Facebook and I don't
think these companies actually
understand how vulnerable they are to
that the second thing that people say is
okay maybe you're right about all of our
economic problems but we're a democracy
and this sounds very nice but the
reality is that Democratic moralism if
it's not backed up by economic and
strategic strength doesn't really go
very far I can't tell you how many
meetings I have been in with African
governments and you know the u.s. some
u.s. embassy person will come in and
rather pathetically say you know you're
doing these deals with China
[Music]
you're really subordinating yourself to
China you should be very concerned about
that
and you know the emerging market person
says yeah and 50 years ago people said
the same thing when we did deals with
the US grow up so it's just not going is
it you know if you cannot actually back
up your system however wonderful you
think it is with actual economic and
political strength III don't see it
really solving any of these problems or
saving you from
inevitable decline and that's more or
less where I think we are heading today
on our way to being going back to being
a sort of second-rate power where we can
sit around and play our political
theater and recite old cold war
propaganda to ourselves but no one will
actually care and there's most of the
propaganda on on trade it's a lot of it
relies on this sort of well free trade
is just the way of the future
there's no other alternative that's it
but from what I can tell and have tried
to present today I think that it's
actually the current system that is
quite regressive that is actually the
dinosaur that's heading to to extinction
that can actually be sustained much
further and I think the only question is
whether we want to go down with it so
with that I will conclude the remarks I
know that was a very positive note but
the only way you solve the problem is to
acknowledge it so thank you very much
thank you we now have time for questions
so please raise your hand and we'll
bring a mic to you
mr. crine are you are you saying that
the bureaucracy and government
regulation in the United States is more
onerous than the bureaucracy of
Communist China no I'm saying it's much
less effective I don't think it's an
issue I think I mean certain that the
Chinese exert more control over their
companies but they do it intelligently
we probably exert less but we have no
strategic goal behind it we we have for
many generations actually thought of
thought of our economy of something
totally separate and adversarial to to
government and we sort of designed a
system in which that's that's how we
regulate things and how we think about
long term planning and government and
industry that's deeply ingrained in us
thinking unfortunately and and maybe
maybe you can say the last 3040 years
are a blip and that will go away but
unfortunately the Asian state capitalism
model has simply been far more effective
at least when it comes to developing
strategic industries and building
strategic industries and I think that
the real problem is not so much you know
whether we have more regulation or less
regulation in China it's the fact that
China is directing its economy very
intelligently and we're sort of throwing
up our hands and saying all that matters
it's the market or all that matters is
you know free trade and not really
thinking about what we want the economy
to do for the larger American national
interest what are your view about fair
trade fair trade fair trade is
it's a way for people so I think the
left on the whole understands the
problems with trade much better than the
right does the problem with the left is
that they really are allergic to
thinking about anything in terms of
national interests or competition and so
fair trade is sort of an attempt to
critique free trade policy without
thinking of it in terms of geopolitical
competition and so it's really about
wages and workers and environmental
stuff and I think all that is true
actually I was having a conversation
with someone it at breakfast and talking
about environmental regulation you know
we tried to impose sort of environmental
regulation without trade without
thinking about its effect on trade
policy well if you do that what happens
is you just take the polluting factory
it moves to China and you've actually
done nothing except hurt yourself and if
you think about you know fair trade is
sort of a greater focus on labor
standards and things like that and all
that's fine but I think you need to go a
little bit further and actually think
about it in terms of national interests
and political competition why has
capital formation in your view been weak
in the United States I'm sorry why has
not capital formation been weak in the
United States so the problem is that the
capital formation itself the problem is
that we are taking we're not we're not
actually investing the capital reform
all we do is recycle it into financial
assets whether it's the S&P 500 or
residential you know luxury residential
real estate it's not actually going into
R&D and you know productive capex
investment that's going to produce the
next the next wave of innovation and
growth so a lot of our financial sector
you know basically all the incentives
that the system have aligned to support
very short-term profit-making incentives
a very kind of myopic sort of
you know IRR calculation type of
investing rather than the sort of big
innovative investments you need now part
of that may be also there's a certain
level we published an article in the
winter issue I think of American affairs
by someone named Henry Kressel who's
former research scientists at RCA labs
and you know about sort of innovation
and investment and a lot of the sort of
basic investing in kind of you know
moonshot projects in in really out there
projects the private sector is not set
up for that the private sector is set up
to converge technologies you really need
the government in the Defense Department
to take the big risks on untested
unproven things so you can argue that
you know it's it's a failure on on that
score that we lost the kind of Cold War
competitive edge in in innovation and
research but the main issue is not
capital formation as such it's the fact
that we have focused entirely on sort of
a cap of capital accumulation in
unproductive assets rather than
productive investment
mr. cry and what do you forecast then if
this decline continues over the next
twenty ten to twenty years of what will
the u.s. look like um I don't know that
it will look all that different because
it's already pretty bad I mean you
already I mean the vast majority of
people work in dead-end service jobs
most of our companies most of the
white-collar companies are sort of just
shuffling paper about recycling money
for no apparent purpose I do think what
will change however is sort of how the
u.s. looks visa vie the rest of the
world and the simple fact is if China is
the largest economy they're going to be
doing the deals they're going to be
controlling they're going to be
controlling you know where things happen
where investment goes not the United
States and increasingly countries will
depend appendant on having a good
relationship with China rather than a
good relationship with the United States
it'll be increasingly attractive for
countries to ally with China to do
China's bidding not the United States
and this isn't just you know some
country in Africa that needs a railroad
build it's going to be it's going to be
Germany Australia everywhere because at
the end of the day you go to where the
money is and the money won't be here my
question concerns Industrial Policy and
in general you sort of alluded to that
isn't though a lot of the problem
they're the same as with any kind of
interventionist policy it's going to get
caught up in the politics the there's
going to be a lot of cronyism the
Friends of the government are going to
get the subsidies or the special deals
and you're going to get in kind of a
deadlock of what the what the policy
ought to be and I guess sort of a second
part I I think about Japan and the 80s
where maybe Japan was sort of where
China is today
and we were told oh we're losing our
auto industry consumer electronics it's
all moving to Japan because they have an
industrial policy and we don't would you
comment on that yeah so first with Japan
well we dealt with Japan in a very open
direct political way we went first of
all we did we did impose a lot of
tariffs on things
second we went over to them and we
signed the plaza Accord and the yen went
from like 300 to 100 and then after that
they had you know the Lost Decade which
they're still unhappy about that and
that may be a reason why it would be
difficult to sign a plasma Court again
but we didn't beat Japan because we
liberated the market we dealt with Japan
as a political actor in a geopolitical
arena and of course it was much easier
to deal with Japan also because they
were a effectively a sort of US ally and
you know still growing out of us
protection under world war ii after
world war ii china will be much more
difficult to deal with and as to
industrial yeah as i said you could
certainly do it stupidly and just having
one will not save you it has to be
intelligent as to work but again China's
managed to do it and yes they have a lot
of corruption in China and there always
is the risk of that but I don't know
that that in itself you know that we did
this stuff in the Cold War it's theirs
there are gonna there's gonna be some
corruption I don't know that that
inherently invalidates the larger point
and the other thing you know I think
it's always interesting to ask these
questions so this may be a generational
thing but in my lifetime sort of
Reaganism has been a tremendous failure
but it worked very well you can't deny
that it worked very well for a time and
it's interesting to sort of think about
why it worked and and now why it doesn't
work and you go back to basically at so
after World War two the US was the only
you know in advanced industrial country
that wasn't totally destroyed so we can
basically do whatever we want and as
that went along
you know a lot of the unions it got out
of hand and so on also you had these
sort of old Cold War giants who had done
a lot to develop new technologies but
like AT&T you know a lot of the sort of
cellphone stuff it was sitting in or
Bell whatever they hadn't done anything
with it the whole Silicon Valley
Internet that was all done by Xerox at
Xerox PARC but it was sitting there they
didn't do anything with it they had to
wait for Bill Gates and Steve Jobs to
come steal it before it went anywhere
and the point I'm getting at is simply
that you know there was a lot of
stagnation with the previous sort of
industrial alignment of the US economy
and it sort of needed to be broken up
the problem is now that there's there's
actually no one producing the the
technologies for people to commercialize
and it's sort of swung the other way and
I think we need to recover a bit of what
we lost and have a more investment
focused approach for the time being and
you also I mean when when the US economy
started to lose ground the last time in
the 70s it's because Japan Germany
they'd all they'd all recovered and come
back and what was interesting then when
we were losing ground you know to tell
the countries that are lost ground too
they tend to have a much more integrated
model of corporate and state and also
unions so Japan Germany they tend to
really integrate their state you know
their largest companies their unions and
the government into into a very unified
system that basically works hand in
glove with each other overseas and
domestically whereas the US has always
had we've always treated a very
adversarial fashion and I think that you
know in every case the US has always
lost ground to that more coordinated
approach whether it has been Japan or
Germany and now China the last time
around we dealt with it as I said this
time around we seem more convinced to
talk about democracy or freedom rather
than to actually defend those things
you seem to be more pro-government
spending and more anti individual
investment your comments regarding
buybacks by corporations whereas they're
returning money really to the investors
to be true to redeploy and what
therefore they feel is the best use of
their own individual capital has
actually been not been very successful
in other words the individual has been
proven in this country to be the best
arbiter of how their own investments and
capital are deployed and if you multiply
that in a macro scale it has been very
good for this country what you're
advocating is that the the government
really makes the determination of how
capital is deployed in the United States
and elsewhere and I know that's been
successful in some countries but on a
macro scale having a lot of individuals
making their own decisions have been
successful for this country how do you
respond to that
well if it's I mean when you say proven
successful where are the numbers and the
problem with share buybacks is it's not
that I have no objection to investors
investing my objection is that investors
do not invest so when you get these
returns of capital the capital just
flows back in to financial assets again
all that happens is the S&P goes from an
astronomical multiple to an astronomical
multiple plus 10 and you feel richer and
it's nice but it's not actually
producing real growth for the future and
I think it would be lovely if individual
companies and individual capital holders
would actually demonstrate a capacity
for investing in the productive
technologies that are necessary to
preserve American dominance in the
future unfortunately they haven't done
that there's simply no evidence for that
and at least not not in recent years and
you know again it's when you're talking
about building you know the next
generation of silicon chips you know
we're not in Adam Smith's world anymore
this is not going to be a family-owned
factory you know kind of old-fashioned
booze wah capital holder it's going to
be a mat you know to build a
semiconductor foundry you know five ten
billion dollars minimum you need a lot
of coordination there's no other player
to provide that coordinate coordination
now you may be right in next year we may
you may come here and China will have
fallen apart and it'll be in the midst
of a brutal civil war maybe but so far
at least they seem to be much more
effective at coordinating their industry
I guess we can agree to disagree on that
but that's my view
hi I'm Victor Claire I'm the BB&T
professor of free enterprise here in
Southwest Florida at Florida Gulf Coast
University over here I have a similar
question to the last questioner if you
visit China in 2018 and you drive around
especially in some of the largest cities
what you see are a lot of ghost housing
developments brand new multi-million
dollar housing projects that were
planned by government but the line from
Field of Dreams if you build it they
will come
turns out not to be true so the
buildings are complete though house
thousands of people yet no Chinese
citizens are occupying them we have our
own housing failures in the United
States cabrini-green is the poster child
for our housing problems rent control is
is a cause of some of our housing
problems and my question for you is this
if neither China nor the US can get
something as basic as housing right what
hope do we have that in heavy investment
in sophisticated technology and
development will be more successful well
I don't I have a hard time seeing the
relevance of that the reality yes of
course they've created some ghost towns
in China you know if you drove her out
Florida right after the housing crash
you see a lot of people kicked out of
their homes so what they've also built a
lot of great semiconductor manufacturing
in China that's a fact we haven't done
it here that's a fact the two are sort
of unrelated and it's always relative so
if you want to say well you know China
isn't perfect and we're not perfect fine
but one of them is less imperfect than
the other at certain areas and we'll see
which areas are more important frankly
the you know residential housing is
probably the least one of the least
productive uses of capital imaginable
and the US has incredible incentives to
encourage exorbitant waste and cost in
in housing and as more and more
financial assets have flowed into real
estate the amount spent on housing only
increases here so you know if
the government wants to create a few
ghost towns in order to hold down the
cost of housing that's probably not a
bad trade-off I really appreciate the
challenges that you presented to us and
I was wondering I just received a new
book probably rent fifteen or twenty
pages the captured economy are you
familiar with the book but they seem to
be arguing that the problem is not
regulation it's rigged regulations would
you comment on that yeah there's no
question that there's truth to that
there's no question that the US has
imposed a lot of regulations that make
little sense or only makes sense in
terms of sort of anti-competitive
effects on new entrants to the industry
I guess I I worry too much about you
know making that the entire problem
though for two reasons one because you
know a lot of this it wastes a lot of
time but it doesn't actually it doesn't
really change anything about you know if
you look at sort of the LNG investment
boom of call it 2010-11 through you know
recent years there's incredibly stupid
regula if you want to build an LNG
processing facility like the regulation
is intense it drags on forever after you
get done with it the Sierra Club sues
you and then they sue again it's it's
not conducive to investment at all on
the other hand though like when when
it's there they all every group went
through this and they ended up being far
more LNG processing plants approved in
the United States than were ever
economically feasible and the other part
of this of course is that it's not
simply the government's fault a lot of
these regulations as you mentioned the
the big cheerleaders of them are the
private sector are the established
players in the private sector and the
only way to roll them back would be
through the state
so again I think it comes down to more
intelligent use of the state rather than
sort of getting rid of it we have time
for one final question
do you see a correlation or just a
coincidence between the decline in
American society and the decline
economically you're describing here in
other words the American families are
falling apart the decline in educational
attainment the decline in the value of
the perceived value of work and working
hard and being responsible and all those
sort of family values that are falling
apart
mass shootings by psychopaths every
other week and so on is that correlated
or is that just coincident with what
you're describing
I think it's correlated and I don't you
know people can get into a big debate
and endless debate about you know our
family's falling apart because people
can't find jobs or our people not
finding jobs because there are no
families to instill work ethic and basic
mores and things like that I don't
really know what the answer to that
question is but I think they are related
the other thing you know we are living
in a society that has basically the
bureaucracy of Brezhnev and the
oligarchs of Yeltsin and a big problem
is that no one actually wants to think
in terms of in any sort of political
community any kind of national interests
you know any discussion of national
interest national goals this this is you
know alarming not only to the left but
to significant parts of the right now
and and that I think is a is a major
cultural change because it until you can
begin to think about sort of you know
larger national interests it's very hard
to address these problems and and like I
said the left sort of the left gets a
lot of the economics of it but they
refuse to actually think about you know
anything that might benefit the United
States which they're frightened of the
right
wants to help the United States but many
of them are well actually shouldn't say
that half the right is fine with the
United States half of it is more
concerned about the market but even
among the half that is fine with the
United States there's an increasing
reluctance to sort of think through the
economics so so that's another I think
you know a deep cultural problem the
Chinese don't have that problem
incidentally but that's a deep cultural
issue that makes it very difficult to
really even talk about this stuff in an
intelligent way and like I said it makes
the allure of free trade everyone's
always winning all the time very
attractive
thanks a lot
[Applause]